and so this was like a sort of yard that
was a pond and we'd built a little river
returning to the wreckage these are the
ashes of Chris Adele's family home here
push fires tore through the house and
the Australian state of New South Wales
destroying everything in their path they
had two hours to gather what they could
and run this is the first time Chris has
properly seen the damage in Chris's wife
Jenny watches on as he summons the
ghosts of their stolen life so we're
standing at the moment in our bedroom
and you can see the remains of our beds
there for more than a decade this was
the place where eight of the family's
children were raised where they kept
precious baby photographs and treasured
love letters but it's all gone
this devastating he goes through all the
different stages of grief you know
you're angry he's sad he's a joke about
it and then he just feel really guilty
that he's not done more
even this metal container was no
protection from the intense heat inside
once-familiar furniture is reduced to
charred flimsy skeletons this twisted
melted bit of metal came from a
motorbike and it shows you the ferocity
of the fire that came through here Chris
and Jenny spent 11 years building
memories and they were taken away in a
matter of minutes more than 300 homes in
eastern Australia have been destroyed in
the recent bush fires four people have
died there is an overwhelming sense of
loss I don't really want to come back
again and see one in C I can see there's
nothing salvageable it'll stay for the
place but yeah I just needed some
closure just mentally to know that that
was it it was fine so you'll never come
back here will never come come back thus
Adele's pain is repeated hundreds if not
thousands of times across this East
Coast as families grieve the memories of
former lives lost to the flames
Siobhan Robbins Sky News rainbow flat
Australia